Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Civilization 6.
Now we got two people; two "friends"  here.
We've got Victoria of the English empire and then we've got Harald Hardrada of the Norwegian empire
Who I'm gonna desperately try not to make fun of, but I know I'm gonna fail
So we gotta see which one of these is gonna be our friend
Because I see in the agendas here, he's got an agenda as the last viking king, and then one hidden agenda,
and I don't know if that's good.
The sun never sets; so the English want to conquer all. But me, I don't like the English - No I love the English.
So there's two more people to meet; we're going to find them
And I'm going to make the best nation possible.
The best nation they ever did see
And we almost got our campus ready, which is about goddamn time
Because we've been waiting FOREVER!
Can we do it now? Do we have it?
Do we have it?  There it is.
Okay so that's good...
We got the scientific capital of the world here
and hopefully that's gonna help us get more stuff done.
But, before we do that we need... we need
(eeu ah..)
I would like that but we don't have time for that
because I need to make another city.
We gotta have it!
But maybe I could just buy one..?
NOPE! I don't have enough gold,
So screw that, we're gonna build one!
I mean do we really need another city?
I mean, probably... but.
Do we really need another city?
Do we REALLY need another city..!?
Oooo!
What is that?
*gasp*
Oh! Cool!
We can just research science.
I dunno why that's gonna benefit anybody...
When has science ever helped the world?!
We don't need to worry about that.
That's not our problem.
Let's just get more cities.
Alright!
*Mark sounds*
Go!
Oh hey!
*Weird accent* "I have traders yous tra- I have sent you traders with gifts of rune stones.
They are powerful--
the stones, not the traders.
"Your delegation is most welcome."
Sorry for mocking you
*Weird accent* "Excellent!"
Oh boy
It's getting worse, it's not even getting close to what it should be.
And it shouldn't be anything!
[Game] "We have an envoy at our disposal"
Yeah!
[Game] "We can use the envoy to gain favor with the city states"
[Game] Becoming friendly with a city-state neighbor can be greatly beneficial to our civilization
Yeah! Let's do that
I already know of Lisbon, let's do that.
I wanna Lisbon it up, how do I Lisbon?
Can I Lisbaan?
Lisbon! Lisbon!
Lisbon!!!!
C'moooooon, Lisbon!
How do I send an envoy? I don't know how to do it.
AH! There we go, I'm sending an envoy.
Yes.
Confirm. Do it, do it.
Hell yeah.
Yeah forget sending envoys to Hardivargan, and Victoria.
We don't need any of that. We got our own. And we got our own problems here.
[Game] My liege, we are beginning to attract the attention
[Game] -of the Great People of the world.
Really?
[Game] Of course, there are other leaders vying for their attention too.
Oh??
[Game] Don't re-invent the wheel.
Hey!
Hey guys!
[Game] Just re-align it.
Guys! Great people of the world!
We got the wheel!
America has the wheel! America was number one.
First at making wheel, maybe, I dunno.
Well we're the best at it. It's made of stone.
And it's square.
It's even better.
I'm gonna get uhhhh, astrology.
I believe there is something else in astrology that we need.
Oh there's another camp? Jeezums.
Get over there.
[Game] Under the-
Oh.
[Game] -White Cliff's battlemented crown, hushed to a depth of more than a Sabbath peace.
Ahh.
It's beautiful!
Why do they get that and not me?
Or did I discover it?
Discovering a natural wonder.
[Game] I don't believe in Astrology, i'm a Sagittarius and we're skeptical.
Ha, that's very funny. But also why didn't they discover it, considering they're very next to it.
Oh well. I wo- I won't mind.
I'll just take the benefits of it.
Who is this anyway-(weird accent) Oh! Is yoo, alright goodbayh.
[Game] All the world’s a stage,
And all the men and women merely players
Hell yeah, we got drama and poetry. Because if there is one thing that Teddy is,
it's dramatic...and poetic? I don't know.
I think I don't know a thing about Teddy Roosevelt at all. I think- I think maybe,
I think maybe Markiplier is just bullshitting his way through this.
I think maybe he's just pretending to know things and then rambling about it,
and hope that no one actually, checks up on his bullshit!
Goddamn it, fuck these guys, the horsemen.
Do I have barbarians? Oh no I do not
You better not ransack my shit, because I'm really tired of..
having my shit ransacked.
Specifically, I don't like-
Hello!
*foreign language*
(adorableness) You say I have a great mind?
I say you have a great beard!
It's WONderful~ It's an honor to meet you~
Come to Brazil, do you know how to dance Samba?
-No! -It doesn't matter, you'll enjoy the carnival regardless.
(adorably) Yes I will! Please!
I need friends so badly!
Alright we'll sample that hospitality
Hell yeah! Hell yeah! I wish this guy wasn't
exploring all that way. Can you explore
over there?
Just go to the ends of the earth. Will
you receive our diplomatic da- sure come
on down
excellent i'll crush you eventually so
don't worry about it
habada boop boop boopadoop ~ Ow!... ~one of these days these
barbarians are going to learn something
about not dying
what does that mean? major defeat?! WHY?! Why?!
Are we at a tactical disadvantage??
that's no good... RUN AWAYYY into the woods!!
Oh jeez! COME ON!! Stop being such a little
baby. Okay get back home, ya baby. --Right so
we got workers here finally --ha hah ha
They just pop in a boat- that's awesome
Yeah! fishing boats hell yeah-- **GASP*
CRAFT??  CRAAFT! --we're gonna have craft...
ok so we're going to have craft down
there --oh Hello!! open borders??!
I don't --you're not even in the same place as
me! Why would you want open b--alright, fine!
if it makes us happier! Ha!
hmm ok thanks Victoria *kiss noise* i thought
that said you have been most kind and
attractive -okay well you know, Teddy is a
handsome man--oh -- *character talks*  ok thanks is
that a euphemism?? Ha! Alright! goodbye!!
thank you?? maybe?? Oh jeez -hey! hey! Whoa
who are these guys?? Who are these guys??
oh it was a mistake to attack Washington
wasn't it?!
oh we took 49 damage
well... that's alright. you guys fortify
until healed... if they do that again
they're really dumb. Oh hit the farm
first and then get the craft
oh hell yes ... --OH!
there's only so much to discover and I'm afraid I can't abide
by anyone who sets out ahead of my own
explorers. - okay...  that's tough shit, Victoria
Teddy's got to explore !! Whoa what we whah whoa wait
whoa! HEY!
what did i do?!?! what did I do?? what? I... I was nice to you! What did I do?? You...you
complimented my N-- or did you compliment your
own Navy?? I don't like this
"Faced with the threat of invasion, people
are ready to come up with innovative
defenses!"
okay... but I don't feel like that was at
all necessary because why the hell did
they attack us???
I do not know. Right so we need to find
another city up by the *weird noises* so
they're still in a cabin up there so
we're going to need a little --right we're
gonna need to just... you know, hold our
horses a little bit because we can't
leave the city because we're kinda stuck
so I need to make spearmen-- ooh --or I can
make a heavy chariot!
I like that!! oh I love a heavy chariot
oh heck yeah! they build a farm... do you
create an escort for me --that's awesome!!!
yeah!! creative escort formation!! cool! nice!
ok you-- what did you just build? *gasp* he built
the granary good for you!
looks like we're finally getting our
heads out of our asses!! what are you
doing? you- you just sleep for a bit, I-- i'll wake
you when it's ready!
don't worry! Just fortify until healed. [GAME]: natural
history of this archipelago is very
remarkable. It seemed to be a little
world within itself.
Mark: i am an explorational wonder..~!
oh! I don't know what benefit that did
but yay!... DISTRICT PILLAGE?? NOO!! MY CAMPUS?!?
OH COME ONN!! god damn it these fucking
barbarians! just fucking kill em!!!
oh you gotta do something so just hit
em! because these stupid a-holes keep-- ugh
They keep pillaging!! they pillaged my campus!! I
needed that!!!
Oh, get the craft, make me feel better
get the craft
ohhh my god damn bullshit... why I'm gonna
try this I don't know if he'll kill you
can you just fall over and die though??
you god damn it! why aren't you dead?!? You've got
like no health
AH!! it's going to ass.  i gotta --ugh, do I have
enough gold to like- Oh, they --OH they both
teamed up against me!!
Pedro help!! I didn't know they both came
up against me! This is just turning to shit
why is because I bet I bet Victoria told
Harold that I was a dick and they all
teamed up against me and they're all a bunch of
assholes my whole everything in
Washington is pillaged i don't know i
haven't fixed that right fine then if
you want to be that way I'm gonna be
this way I'm going to freaking by a
heavy chariot we're gonna kick you in the dick!
i'm gonna kick you in the dick we're
gonna kick you in your god damned if
I'll go get my craft fucking get some
graft finally I got the crap i've been
craving for Jeezums so this assholes over
here but I got heavy Zoroastrianism
where did you go??
you can't run from my heavy Jerry you
can't exactly run from my of each area
but i won't like it
her work on it for you don't run away
and you hold still die just die
good job you dead okay now I'm gonna
kill these Scouts be Scouts have been
here forever and I haven't taken care of them
it's time to clean house here because
holy shit, haven't been doing that
kill him kill him excuse me did I run
over your face with my chariot I'm so
sorry that didn't do nearly enough
damage i need to buy another not a gold
course I am
choose a pant- wahh.... a pantheon? ooooh
This would be useful considering i have two
minds but i'm all about them fertility rights
hell yeah, hell yeah
oh wait - what is this..?
naw i'm all about the fertility rights
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
goddamn it my city is just in Ashes...
Pedro! buddy
Pedro help please please help i need...
it's not even an option I got to be
friendly imma send a delegation we
politely refuse your delegation wow you
you showed me the wonders of Brazil I
have no friends I have no friends I might
as well kill this guy is that now
oh well it's ok i have no right let's go
kill some more people
oh hi hello because every day on tap
sure about the true confidential under a
bargain tone monkey mia smiles for
yourself Jochen can have some meat to
actually talk about ok i'll rule my land
so long as you don't try to rule my land
as well because you seem to be ruling a
lot of lands as well as burgundy and I'm
going to meet you will you be my friend
let's be friends because I've got a lot
of enemies right now have a delegation
your envelope arrived and I welcome them
personally our Empire could benefit of
diplomacy my last name is fish box on
German - you like me?
yeah okay the clear surprised were can
you be nice to me not war
ok send a delegate to ok screw you find
who needs orders settler
alright fine over there is not going
well for me hello we set a diplomatic
envoy to you treat them as you would
treat me the Duke of Swabia king of
Burgundy king of Germany king of the
Romans king of Italy and holy Roman emperor...
Okay...you are very egotistical but
i like that. Delegation more most welcome
my chariot you go over here
mysticism finalists to mysticism
yeah and we got another chariot hooray
we're gonna beat the shit out of
everybody you wait there you wait there
Bubba you wait there baby boom because i
need 20 it's repairing it doesn't
ok that's at least good it repairs
itself oh no wait i need to repair it
god damn it
yeah final repaired cheese's cheese's oh
hello open borders of course maybe I
should have accepted open borders for
the victoria ok
vonderful indeed are you gonna be my
friend now can i send you a delegation
delegation
oh come on don't be so stingy. Be cool man
cool about the odd friends with
Frederick Barbarossa he's my friend okay
nevermind nevermind ok no friends okay
we're not friends I just shouted that
from the rooftops for no reason but okay
guess we're just not friends that's how it goes
everybody has progressed from classical
era to the medieval era wow i am i'm
lagging behind then one man's magic
yeah the man's engineering yeah we got
engineering it's about damn time took me
a long time but I finally got it
can I get this major defeat oh don't
tell me chariots are bad against that uh
haha i suck so much dick
oh god and the worst oh no what have I
done their Spearman of course are good
against horses on my cities are in ruin
and I've done horrible things can you
change your production pleased to shift
all of that towards like us
beer man we've done bad haven't we
we've done very bad about what are you
doing Haho huh
what are you gonna do now oh you have no
city to fortify yourself it's still very
bad for me to attack you live what he
gonna do now huh this was a bad idea
wasn't it ok it's a bad idea
alright so you Baltimore you're
basically screwed so why not make a
builder instead of doing something that
can actually protect you don't know
oh god oh no no no my porch area
my poor guy oh he didn't do so good i
mean he did better on the defensive than
he did on the offensive so I guess
that's good you just fortify their can
you uh you go attack that guy root beer
and then leave Baltimore defenseless
yeah that's that's what I should have
done what i was doing is I was opening
up so I could buy like a warrior
then I got him and he's defending the
city oh I'm spending all my gold because
I'm an idiot
yeah yeah immediate yeah oh shit haha oh
come on the whole chariot istics bloated
oh no well kill these douchebags pesky
good job Baltimore yes sure did it you
did it and I'm proud of you
you did it good I can't wait to see what
you're gonna do again
also i forgot i'm at war Germany
denounced the evil deeds of Norway ya go
germany go alright that's my buddy
Germany don't mind as I kill this poor
defenseless Scout he deserved it he was an a-hole
oh hello I will destroy my enemies and
if you continue to help them I will
destroy you as well I help no
buddy I was helping I only help you good
buddy frederick i love you so he's
unfriendly with Pedro but Peter was a
dick to me anyway so you know I i don't
i don't wanna - oh no he's unfriendly with me
oh no bueno okay i want to be friend
with this make him happy if i denounced
Pedro Pedro rejected me so fuck you Pedro!
this situation is going to get worse
before it gets any better oh really
or you upset about that Pedro I'm sorry
well what a dick to do good Frederick
Frederick to tell you good detective who
you do good Frederick did you good good
idea now Joe these guys who make peace
I'd like to make peace yep that possible
we make peace make this deal more to go
make peace cannot accept this deal
well okay how about you give me gold and
we make peace
that's a good option or dobson are fine
goodbye but I'm gonna laugh when it's
Gandhi behind-the-scenes been
manipulating all this son-of-a-bitchery
ok just explore kill anybody you
see blah blah blah ok we got another
chariot which is not exactly what we
needed but ok we need more builders who
mushy this completes the superintendent
these guests make this video is that
Nina so Haley's at home
ok did you just come here to brag dude
because honestly i don't care
i denounced you, you're a douche
although the Norwegian fella did say
something similar before he tricked me
I'd better go nuclear right now who
envoy I'm gonna max out Lisbon because I
need money which means that I need other
stuff to manage it just sucks i'm not
where i want to be because i was set
back so much by freaking barbarians and
then everyone wants to kill me only
Frederick's my friend and Frederick's an asshole!
everyone knows that one more asshole is
Gandhi back
oh that doesn't look
good is that England stuff maybe you should kill them
what are you doin? what are you doing there?
you wanna fight? Habooskie
I don't get you take that England that
we we we shot a few arrows at you and
you you hurt real bad
yeah that's right oh yeah we'll get you
again have to take that England the yeah
we don't like you you declared war on us
now declare war on the ocean
yeah you better run away alright you
want some you want some you want him and
you're gonna get some yeah that's right
*Mark sounds*
yeah that's what you get you can't beat my
ships what you brought me my ships
very easily because my ships are doing
exactly look but anyway you know the
principle of the thing I build her can
you fix these tricked-up improvements
while Jesus was at him hit him hard
nice about you get promoted
um no comments thanks hell yeah hit him
hit him hard
ok go over there fix that improvement no
shit i should just put one down there
wasn't anything i'm an idiot who natural
philosophy would be great yes please
yes please
okay build the quarry oh good finally the
past year man I'm just beating the shit
out of this one thing here all its
despair bit
Oh No England what are you gonna do was
at Carthage oh shit is that Carthage's
fingers ah damn it out did I screw up
bad oh no I didn't mean to hit Carthage
Carthage is just an innocent city-state
what I was trying to beat up England I'm
a bad man oh well whatever point you
blink and hitting there with your angle
and hit them hit them hard
yeah England, you like that? i don't think you do
Teddy Roosevelt don't take no shit
from nobody
um, where they go they run away like little
babies yes they did out how we that
didn't hurt at all
it hurt almost exactly none
ok nevermind then we're gonna keep
carrying on my nose
sorry Carthage you stay cool Carthage
your cool Carthage you I build up brand landation
and we got silk now, right?
does that mean we have cells that better
mean we have sickly little if we don't
have silk I'm gonna be very pissed
ow oh ow no it hurts so badly
doesn't need to die
okay yeah it's starting to get hopeless
I'm gonna have them get out there a
bendable out how you got one of my ships
will rebuild it when we fortify and
he'll I don't know if they can do that
but I well whatever are we don't have
enough damage going on there so just get
back home somehow look
all that craft look at all that crap i
want that graph what are you doing
where are you norway norway i don't like
that Norway you stay out of their Norway
you stay away from my nanners norway
norway and going to take my nanners
money and my neighbors are your manners
damn he's got me cornered here but he's
gonna die nonetheless
what does he take serious Norwegian
pillaged what now
when did the Norwegian bastards do that
fuck fuck you and all you do
fuck you i can't even get my galley out
of there but fuck you can I hit that guy
million him hit him hard
ah damn it offensive tactic ok anyway
I'm all I have time for this one
things are getting heated here but maybe
someday we could make peace you bitch
you fucking asshole with your stupid
face in your ugly-ass beard and your
weird clothes and funny accent you with
your dumb helmet with his too small for
your stupid head
let's make peace buddy..let's make peace, come on man
come on live a little...live a little. Come on man
that night about about 50 gold hundred
fit hot you are fat nevermind I'm gonna
fuck you up nonetheless yes stupid poop
I so anyway I'm all out of time I'm i'm
really loving this game like I remember
why I really like this game because it's
super two bridges it's just enjoyable
it's just something that's like a
worthwhile endeavor
what is that over there ok cool but
either way that is all the time that I
have available for now I'm nowhere near
getting any great people
so anyway that's all good for them
they've they've already got a bunch of
great people i didn't get any great people
why not wait what was I supposed to try
to do this
oh I see I've been being dumb
oh I'm an idiot i'm not doing anything
of here
well alright then whoopsie-doopsie
wasn't focusing on nothing i'm doing
terribly world rankings i'm in fifth
place I'm in sixth place on the fourth
place on this is what ok so anyway I'm
doing terribly but as i said i was
supposed to be doing terribly so I don't
want to do any more videos of this was a
lot of fun it take a long long time for
me to even finish this game and I'd
probably just lose anyway so thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope you enjoy this
I had a lot of fun with it, hope you did
too thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video Buh-bye!
*outro music*